what do you think is there on that
subconscious what do you think of the
younging as Shadow is what what's there
you know there's this idea as if you're
familiar with too I'm sure that this
jungian idea that there we all have all
things inside of us that all of us have
the capacity to be evil to be good Etc
but that some people Express one or the
other to a greater extent but he also
mentioned that there's a unique
category of people maybe two to five
percent of people that don't just have
all things inside of them but they
actually spend a lot of time exploring a
lot of those things the darker recesses
the Shadows their own Shadows
um
you know I'm somebody who's drawn to
goodness and to light and to Joy and all
those things like anybody else but I
think um maybe it's part of how I grew
up maybe it was the crowd I was with
um
um maybe but then again you know even
when I started spending more time with
academics and scientists I mean
um you see shadows in other ways right
you see pure ambition with no passion I
I recall a colleague
um in San Diego who it was very clear to
me did not actually care about
understanding the brain but
understanding the brain was just his
Avenue to exercise ambition and if you
gave him something else to work on he'd
work on that in fact he did he left and
he worked on something else I realized
he has no passion for understanding the
brain like all the I assumed all
scientists do certainly why I went into
it but some people it's just raw
ambition it's about winning it doesn't
even matter what they win to which to me
is crazy but I think that's a shadow
that some people explore not when I've
explored
um I think the shadow parts of us are
very important to come to understand and
look better to understand them and know
that they're there
and work with them then to not
acknowledge their presence and have them
surface in the form of addictions or
behaviors that um that damage Us in
other people so one of the processes for
achieving mental health is to bring
those things to the surface so fish the
subconscious mind yes and um and you
know he Paul describes 10 cupboards that
one can look into for exploring the self
there's the structure of self and the
function of self again this will all be
spelled out in the series in a lot of
detail also in terms of its relational
aspect between people how to pick good
partners and good relationship gets
really into this from a very different
perspective
um yeah fascinating stuff I was just
sitting there just I will say this that
that four episode series with Paul
is at least to date the most important
work I've ever been involved in
in all of my career because it's very
clear that we are not taught how to
explore our subconscious yeah and that
very few people actually understand how
to do that even most psychiatrists he
has a uh he mentioned something about
psychiatrists you know if you're a
cardiothoracic surgeon or something like
that and 50 of your patients die you're
considered a bad cardiothoracic surgeon
but with no disrespect to psychiatrists
there are there are some excellent
psychiatrists out there there are also a
lot of terrible psychiatrists out there
because unless all of those all of their
patients commit suicide or half commit
suicide they can treat for a long time
without it becoming visible that they're
not so good at their craft now he's
superb at his craft and
um I think he would say that yes
exploring some Shadows but also just
understanding the self like what what
you know really under understanding like
like who am I and and what's important
what are my ambitions what are my
striving again I'm lifting from some of
the things that that he'll describe
exactly how to do this
people do not spend enough time
addressing those questions and as a
consequence they discover what resides
in their subconscious through the
sometimes bad hopefully all also good
but um manifestations of their actions
they're we are driven by this huge 90 of
our real estate that is not visible to
our conscious awareness and we we need
to understand that you know I've talked
about this before I've done therapy
twice a week since I was a kid I had to
as a condition of being let back in
school
um I continue I found a way to either
through insurance or even when I didn't
have insurance I took an extra job
writing for Thrasher magazine when I was
a postdoc so I could pay for therapy at
a discount because I didn't make much
money as a postdoc I mean I think for me
it's as important as going to the gym
and people think it's just you know
ruminating on problems or getting no no
if you work with somebody really good
they're forcing you to ask questions
about who you really are what you really
want
um it's not just about support but there
should be support there should be
Rapport but then it's also
there should be Insight right most
people who get therapy they're getting
support there's rapport but Insight is
not easy to arrive at and a really good
psychologist or psychiatrist can help
you arrive at Deep insights that
transform your entire life well
sometimes when I look inside and I do
this often
you know exploring who you truly are you
come to this question
do I accept once you see parts do I
accept this or do I fix this is this a
is this who you are fundamentally
and it will always be this way or is
this a problem to be fixed like for
example one of the things
especially recently but in general over
time I've discovered about myself
probably has roots in childhood probably
has roots and a lot of things as I
deeply value loyalty
maybe more than the average person and
so when there's disloyalty it can be
painful to me and so this is who I am
and so do I have to
relax a bit
do I have to fix this part or is this
who you are and there's a million that's
one like little I think loyalty is a
good thing to cling to provided that
when loyalty is broken that it doesn't
um disrupt too many other areas of your
life but it depends also on who's
disrupting that loyalty if it's a
co-worker versus a romantic partner
versus your exclusive romantic partner
depending on the structure of your
romantic partner life you know I mean I
have always experienced extreme
um
joy and feelings of safety and Trust in
my friendships again mostly male
friendships with female friendships do
which is only to say that they were
mostly male friendships the female
friendships have also been very loyal
um let you know so getting backstabbed
is not something I'm familiar with
um and yeah I love being crewed up you
know yeah no for sure and I'm with you
and you know you and I are very much
have the same values on this but you
know that's one little thing and then
there's many other things like I'm
extremely self-critical and you look at
my you know I look at myself as I'm
regularly very self-critical there's a
self-critical engine in my brain and I
talked to actually Paul about this I
think on the podcast quite a bit and
he's saying this is a really bad thing
like you need to fix this you need to be
able to be regularly very uh positive
about yourself and I kept disagreeing
with them no this is like who I am like
you and it seems to work don't mess with
the thing that seems to be working it's
fine like I oscillate between being
really grateful and really self-critical
but then you have to like figure out
what is it maybe is there's a deeper
root thing there's maybe there's an
insecurity in there somewhere that has
to do with childhood and are you trying
to prove something to somebody from your
childhood this kind of thing well a
couple things that I think are
hopefully valuable for people here one
is
um
one way to destroy your life is to spend
time trying to control your or somebody
else's past
so much of our destructive Behavior
and thinking comes from wanting
something that we saw or did or heard
to not be true
rather than really working with that and
getting close to what it really was and
you know sometimes those things are even
traumatic and we need to really get
close to them and and for them to move
through us and and that you know there
are a bunch of different ways to do that
with support from others and hopefully
but sometimes on our own as well I don't
think we can rewire our deep preferences
and what we find Despicable or joyful
I do think that
it's really a question of what allows us
peace like can you be at peace with the
fact that you're very self-critical and
enjoy that get some distance from it
have a sense of humor about it or is it
driving you in a way that's keeping you
awake at night and yeah
um and forcing you back to the table to
do work in a way that feels
self-flagellating and doesn't feel good
um you know can you get that humility
and awareness of how you're you know of
your one's flaws and I think that that
that can create you know this word space
sounds very new age you like get space
from it is that you know you can have a
sense of humor about how how neurotic we
can all be I mean you know neurotic
isn't actually a bad term in the classic
sense of the psychologists and
psychiatrists the freudians said that
you know the best case is to be neurotic
to actually see one's own issues and
work with them whereas psychotic is the
other is the other way to be uh which is
obviously not good so I think um the
question whether or not to work on
something or to
um just accept it as part of ourselves I
think really depends if we feel like
it's holding us back or not and I I
think you're asking perhaps the most
profound question about being a human
which is you know what what do you do
with your body what do you do with your
mind I mean if you it's also a question
we started off talking about Fitness a
little bit which is for whatever reason
um you know
do I need to run an Ultra
you Marathon no I don't feel like I need
to
um David
Goggins does and it does a whole lot
more than that so that for him that's
important for me it's not important to
do that I don't think he does it just so
he can run the Ultras
um there's clearly something else in
there for him and guys like Kim Haynes
and and uh tremendous respect for for
what they do and how they do it
um
does one need to make their body more
muscular stronger more endurance more
flexibility do you need to read harder
books do you need to I think doing hard
things feels good
um I think it I know it feels good I
know that the worse I feel the worst way
to feel
is when I'm procrastinating and I don't
do something and then whenever I do
something and I complete it and I break
through that point where it was hard and
then I'm doing it at the end I actually
feel like I was infused with some sort
of
um super chemical and who knows if it's
probably a cocktail of endogenously made
chemicals but I think it is good to do
hard things but you have to be careful
not to destroy your body your mind in
the process and I think it's about
whether or not you can achieve peace can
you sleep well at night stress isn't bad
if you can sleep well at night you can
be stressed all day go go go go go go go
go and it'll optimize your focus but can
you fall asleep and stay deeply sleep at
night
um being in a hard relationship some
people say you know
that that's not good other people like
it can you be at peace in that and I
think uh we all you know I have
different RPM that you know we all kind
of idol at different RPM and
um some people are big Melo costellos
and others are kind of like you know
need more friction in order to to feel
at peace but I think ultimately what we
want is to feel at peace
we have
um been through some really low points
over the past couple years and I think
the reason could be boiled down
to the fact that I haven't been able to
find a place of peace a a place or
people or moments that give deep inner
peace
I yeah I you know
and I think you put it really
beautifully it's uh you have to figure
out given Who You Are
the various
um characteristics of your mind all the
things all the contents of the cupboards
uh how to how to get space from it and
ultimately one good representation of
that is to be able to laugh at all of it
whatever whatever's going on inside your
mind to be able to step back and just
kind of chuckle at the at the beauty and
the absurdity of the whole thing yeah
and keep going there's this beautiful uh
as I mentioned seems like every podcast
lately
um I'm a huge rancid fan mostly because
I just think Tim Armstrong's writing is
is pure poetry and whether or not you
like the music or not
um you know and he's written on music
for a lot of other people too he's not
doesn't advertise that much because he's
humble but I end up by the way I went to
a show of theirs like 20 years ago oh
yeah I'm going to see them in Boston in
September 18th I'm literally flying
there for for
um uh or I'll take the train up from New
York I'm gonna meet a friend of mine
named Jim thibo who's a big guy who owns
a lot of companies in skateboard
industry um we're meeting there like a
couple little kids to go see them play
amazing amazing people amazing music
music very intense very intense and but
embodies all the different emotions
that's why I love it right they have
some love songs they have some hate
songs they have some and um but you know
there's a going back to what you said I
think there's a there's a song the first
song on the Indestructible album I think
it there's a
um it's sort of he's just talking about
like shock and disbelief of discovering
things about people that were close to
you and you you know it's
um I won't I won't sing it but you know
nor I wouldn't dare but um but there's
this one lyric where that's really stuck
in my mind for for ever since that album
came out in 2003 which is
um you know
that nothing's what it seems so I just
sit here laughing I'm gonna keep going
on I can't get distracted there is this
piece of like you got to learn how to
push out the disturbing stuff sometimes
and go forward and I mean I remember
hearing that lyric and and then writing
it down and you know that was a time
where my undergraduate advisor who was
like a a mentor and a father to me you
know blew his head off in the bathtub
like three weeks before and then my
graduate advisor who I was working for
at that time who I loved and adored was
really like a mother to me I knew her
when she was pregnant with her two kids
died at 50. breast cancer and then my
postdoc advisor you know first day of
work at Stanford as a faculty member
sitting across the table like this from
him had a heart attack right in front of
me died of pancreatic cancer at the end
of 2017. I remember just thinking like
you know going back to that song lyric
over and over like and where people
would
um you know I haven't had many betrayals
in life I've had a few but just thinking
like we're seeing something or learning
something about something you just like
you can't believe it and I I I mentioned
that that lyric off that first song
Indestructible on that album because
it's this the emo like just the raw
emotion of like I can't believe this
what I just saw is so disturbing
but I have to just keep going forward
there are certain things that we really
do need to push not just into our
periphery but off into the gutter and
keep going and that's a hard thing to
learn how to do but
if you're going to be functional in life
you have to and actually just to get at
this issue of do I change or do I
embrace this aspect of self
um about six months it was April
um
of this last year I did some intense
work around some things that were really
challenging to me and I did it alone and
it may have involved some medicine and I
expected to get peace through this I was
like I'm gonna let go of the and I spent
11 hours just getting more and more
frustrated and angry about this thing
that I was trying to resolve and I was
so unbelievably disappointed that I
couldn't get that relief and I was like
what is this like this is not how this
is supposed to work I'm supposed to be
feel peace the clouds are supposed to
lift and so a week went by
and then another half week went by and
then someone who I whose opinion I trust
very much I explained this to them
because I was getting a little concerned
like what's going on this is worse not
better and they said this is very simple
you have a giant blind spot
which is your sense of justice Andrew
and your sense of anger are linked like
an iron rod
and you need to relax it
and as they said that I felt the anger
dissipate and so there was something
that I think is it is true I have a very
strong sense of justice and my sense of
anger
then at least uh was very strongly
linked to it so it's great to have a
sense of justice right I hate to see
people wrong I absolutely do and I'm
human I'm sure I've wronged people in my
life I know I have they've told me I've
tried to apologize and reconcile where
possible still have a lot of work to do
um but
where I see Injustice it draws in my
sense of anger in a way that I think is
just eating me up and but it was only in
hearing that link that I wasn't aware of
before it was in my subconscious
obviously
um did I feel the relaxation it wasn't
there's no amount of plant medicine or
MDMA or any kind of you know chemical
you can take that's naturally just going
to dissipate what's hard for oneself it
needs if one Embraces that or if one
chooses to do it through just talk
therapy or journaling or friends or
introspection or all of the above there
needs to be an awareness of the things
that we're just not aware of so I think
the answer to your question do you
Embrace or do you fight these aspects of
self is
um I think you get in your subconscious
through good work with somebody skilled
or and sometimes that involves the tools
I just mentioned in various combinations
and you figure it out you figure out if
it's serving you obviously it was not
bringing me peace it was undermining my
my sense of justice was undermining my
sense of peace and so in understanding
this link be now I would say that the in
understanding this link between Justice
and anger now I think it's a little bit
more of like uh
you know it's not like a Twizzler stick
bendy but it's at least it's not like an
iron Rod like you know when I see
somebody wronged I mean it used to just
like like immediately but you're able to
step back now that's like to me the
ultimate place to reach
is laughter
I just sit here laughing exactly that's
that's the lyric I like I can't believe
it so I just sit here laughing like
can't get distracted just you just at
some point but the but the problem I
think in just laughing at something like
that gives you distance
but the question is
does do you stop engaging with it at
that point like I experienced this I
mean recently I got to see how sometimes
I'll see something that's just like what
like this is crazy so I just laugh but
then I continue to engage in it and it's
taking me off of course and so there is
a place where you know I mean I get
realize this is probably a kid's show
too so I want to keep it you know
G-rated but at some point for certain
things it makes sense to go
that